ah yes but I saw dude I watched F9 Fast
and the Furious and then I looked I I
I don't understand what F9 is you know
top 10 worst movies of all time like Vin
Diesel doesn't hey dude you that's not
the movie you're in guy you're not in
you know Thriller drama
[ __ ] everything serious movie guy
you're you're in a movie where a car
has an RMB singer and a rapper in it and
it goes to outer space to save the world
a car
you're in a movie where a pro wrestler
John SEMA Cena who I would argue is the
worst looking man in human history
okay
[ __ ]
aggressively advances off a [ __ ]
ledge and [ __ ] in a car and zooms off
it and a [ __ ]
stealth bomber picks it up sit up in
midair
and Vin Diesel's like
seriously looking at another guy saying
stuff like
no not this time I was there for you and
like doing it like for real hey do it
tongue-in-cheek
it's F9
hey do it tongue-in-cheek you made nine
of these and the only reason why they're
[ __ ] Global box office phenomenons is
because of Asians
Asians don't give a
[ __ ] what they're watching dude Asians
will watch anything as long as something
in it Preposterous is happening
like they they don't give a [ __ ] dude
and a white guy will watch the stealth
bomber pick up a [ __ ] car in midair
and and white guy be like oh my god what
the [ __ ] Asians will watch it and eat
start eating more popcorn
it's the Asians don't give a [ __ ] as
long as action is happening right and
I'm including Indians with RR like all
that Bollywood [ __ ] they don't give a
[ __ ]
and there's so many of them that [ __ ]
Fast and Furious can be a hit now and
that's a conspiracy theory Hill that I'm
willing to die on
uh
yeah dude
so don't be all not tongue-in-cheek and
sitting there Vin Diesel talking to you
know somebody that's like it's actually
all about family and mean it dude get
out of here man
get you know
somebody who guy I [ __ ] dude vindi
John Cena is the ugliest man I've ever
seen in my life
I'll die on the hill dude have you ever
seen a close-up of him he looks
fantastic in the ring but you see a
close-up with that [ __ ] dude oh
you're just like where's his
going
is his face in a rush
parts of his face have other [ __ ] to do
today or something
it's a comedy podcast relax dude
I don't actually think John Cena is the
ugliest guy in the [ __ ] world I think
it's Kenneth Branagh obviously but dude
you know what I mean where's hey but
where's Kenneth brana's lips though
they use that extra flesh to populate
John Cena's [ __ ] face with like jowls
you know
God was like Kenneth doesn't need that
put it on John Cena's jowls
obviously I'm joking dude Kenneth Brana
is not the [ __ ] ugliest guy in the
world
I mean I could keep going with the joke
you know but it's just like
but yeah dude
just like
John Cena's where's his face going dude
John Cena's got the most faceiest face
since Steve Harvey
[Music]
um
the acting I know I know you don't watch
but so this is what my point is I'm
watching F9 and then I look I'm like oh
this is agreed that this is one of the
worst movies we've ever seen right like
where do they get hey
like where do they get first of all who
are these guys in Fast and Furious
Furious who are these guys okay because
let's go back to Fast and the Furious
one
Paul Walker was an undercover cop that
met up with a street racer Vin Diesel
and they had to save the day or uncover
something or [ __ ] get bad guys
arrested okay
how did we get to
the ninth installment which is actually
the tenth installment because of Hobbs
and Shaw's in there somewhere
how the [ __ ] did they get to be Global
like International spies that like Vin
Diesel's like we're needed again
to save the world oh by what but who's
hiring you
you just some guy
and and and who's ludicrous
and what it what is Tyrese
and how are they the comedic [ __ ]
element of the movie
cars will be flying off for Bridges and
ludicrous would be like
not in my wildest days whoa
and Tyrese will just be like damn
Asians just eating popcorn more popcorn
just laughing their [ __ ] asses off
watching Fast and Furious and [ __ ] uh
you know
a big metropolitan area
ah dude
[ __ ] God damn dude nothing there's
only one thing more Asian than being in
a heavily populated metropolitan area is
being [ __ ] away way way not near
[ __ ] anybody do it in silence yeah
dude man
holy [ __ ] so but I will tell you this
man who who are these guys in the movie
just straight up who are they
1900 characters in each movie dude Kurt
Russell is in number nine in two scenes
shot it in one day it gave him four
million dollars took an afternoon
and like you know
who are these guys who is Charlize
Theron she's in a glass box the whole
movie
with a [ __ ] a Q-tip haircut
who are these people
then you got like Michelle Rodriguez who
I thought was Vin Diesel's sister until
they ended up kissing and I'm like oh oh
it's [ __ ] Jordana Brewster that's his
sister just there's too many people in
this movie
dude John Cena Vin Diesel the chick from
Game of Thrones that's now in that
invitation thing that used to follow me
on [ __ ] Instagram but doesn't anymore
and then [ __ ] uh
Jordana Brewster [ __ ] uh what's her
name uh the other one that I just said
Michelle Rodriguez
ludicrous Tyrese I'm racist because I
had to do black guys at the same time uh
the Asian dude that just acts like this
that's all he does well what do you
think he's just
we thought you died whoa not today
just ludicrous [ __ ] yucking it up
God Ludacris the worst act I've ever
seen my life dude
they tell
hey also
in oh I forgot the best part John Cena
is Vin Diesel's brother
[Laughter]
John Cena
is Vin Diesel's brother in the movie
they don't look alike
dude and there's this there's a and then
it might have been okay if they were
adopted but they don't mention that as a
matter of fact they make it worse they
say oh I knew I noticed that jawline and
the face structure was familiar saying
like that they actually were brothers
dude ah
ah
if they cast straight up if they cast a
[ __ ] doorway instead of John Cena it
would have been more believable
did Vin Diesel looks more like a doorway
than John Cena
is Vin Diesel even white I don't even
know what the [ __ ]
dude unbelievable that their brothers in
the movie dude dude
here's another question who's funding
this mission
it's hey Street racer we need help to
save the world can you find this orb
that's in the wrong hands here's 84
bajillion dollars this seems a pro-free
appropriate
howdy does it
wow dude just unbelievable I can't even
believe it
that Asian guy is in it and it's so
funny dude
like he's that he like
he died in the movie before and died and
then they were like
how you alive and then he's just like
and they do some flashback where instead
of him being in the car that blew up
he's watching the car that blew up
and then he shows up and he has a
haircut you know to make him look older
he just [ __ ] has a haircut and [ __ ]
and then and then it goes and then it
goes and then one of the guys says to
him well that still leaves one thing
that has to be left explained and and
then I and then I said to my friends we
were watching it I said your haircut and
they all laughed really hard
[Music]
dude that movie dude F also the balls to
call it F9 made half a billion dollars
it cost it made 750 or 20 30 40 50
million dollars cost 200 something
million dollars to make so much [ __ ]
money just being thrown around dude and
and Kurt Russell's in two scenes and
then at the end he's he his character's
name is Mr Nobody dude a children's game
so bad and and then isn't discussed
Beyond halfway through in the throughout
the movie and the movie ends and there's
like no car Russell and then three days
later you think wait a minute Kurt
Russell was in that movie
and they're making another one
they're just waiting for the CGI to get
good enough because because they just
cut Paul Walker out because he died that
they're just gonna wait till the CGI is
good enough to where they're gonna I
swear to God I [ __ ] you not to where
they can CGI and have Paul Walker in the
whole movie CGI that's what they're
gonna do and I'm telling you right now
dude and they've already put ludicrous
and Tyrese in space in a car and they
had to crash into a satellite this is
all real [ __ ]
um
movie's so bad but it's great and then I
went down the [ __ ] critic this whole
reason I brought up and the critics and
and like half the critics were like
popcorn fun no
still gotta make sense dude
you know the acting may not be there but
the action is absolutely non-stop yeah
but it's bad dude the special effects
okay but also this is a movie
I could just type cool special effects
on YouTube and come up with them it's
just so bad dude
um
oh come on
oh God Vin Diesel dude do you know his
real name I do it's Mark Sinclair
a [ __ ] lawyer you know
well judge that would be cool but he
didn't do it why
family
drives out of the [ __ ] Courtyard
knocks over a fountain
diesel said he prefers to maintain his
privacy regarding his personal life
stating dude he saw somebody I went to
win would have went to NYU for one year
with uh stating I'm not gonna put it out
there on a magazine cover like some
other actors I come from the
Harrison Ford Marlon Brando Robert De
Niro Al Pacino Code of Silence and lump
tires and afford in there you know like
not part of it
I'm from [ __ ] I'm from the hair I'm
from the Marlon Brando Robert De Niro Al
Pacino Drew Carey Code of Silence
what Harrison Ford was in Zero Italian
movies Dakota silence is Italian
you know
I'm from the I'm from the Marlon Brando
Robert De Niro Al Pacino Frankie Muniz
Code of Silence we don't talk about our
private life
the guy's Instagram is unreal too Vin
Diesel oh such a kink in his neck here
with the [ __ ] uh what's his name
Michael Marco Kaine oh couldn't think of
his name until I did that one of the fun
one of the best this is his caption one
of the best things about filming in the
UK dinners with my dear friend Sir
Michael Kane who adoringly refers to me
as his son
dude all love always I love people who
sign their Instagram captions all love
always dude it's not a [ __ ] letter
you're gonna give to a pigeon
uh kink in his neck you know how much
does Vin Diesel wear the worst clothes
of all time I've never seen him in his
regular clothes only in action clothes
but
wow these two guys are probably so
[ __ ] imagine being at a dinner with
goddamn Michael Kane and Vin Diesel you
I swear to God 20 minutes in I'd be like
dude I I come out I'm out dude I'm out
I'm out
I can't do this dude
you [ __ ] guys kidding me you don't
know what real life is life
okay I'm looking here another Instagram
wow yeah this [ __ ] Michael Caine also
not a Code of Silence
[Music]
[Music]